le 30 novembre 2016 le tribunal
correctionnel de besançon reconnaissez
le chru coupable de mise en danger
délibérée de la vie d'autrui
il lui est reproché d'avoir fait
travailler entre 2009 et 2013
des agents techniques sans protection
dans des zones où elles connaissaient
l'existence d'amiante
les ouvriers avaient alors porté plainte
ainsi que le chsct et quatre syndicats à
l'issue du procès le centre hospitalier
de besançon est condamné à une amende
avec sursis un jugement historique car
c'est la première fois qu'un
établissement public et condamné en tant
que personne morale
mais la partie civile et la défense juge
le délibéré ambiguë les 48 plaignants
dont quatre avaient été déboutés dénonce
une peine trop légère
le 14 juin 2018 la direction de
l'hôpital fait appel après quatre mois
de délibéré la cour de besançon doit
rendre sa décision cet après midi à
l'aise ratel la responsabilité de
l'hôpital où ira-t-elle plus loin dans
le son est victime
la parole est de nouveau à la justice